welcome to this video playing acha boys
in the house and this is Austria right
yeah I got that right for once acaba
who's our cabin probably I'm outing
myself as some sort of ignorant who's
our kebabs the subtext in them nope ok
so we have a sloth and it's a fairly
strategical way to play the Slavs white
with Quincy to this is a favorite of the
the late on polish-american grand masta
ace and avoid kovitch he won many many
games in this this type of position and
probably played it somewhat differently
than I did so not too too great here I
don't have any problems but i also don't
have any big ideas in this position now
i can can try c5 before this is typical
kind of advanced but he's ready to play
five and ya still what else
before I can play you can just play a
six-time term keep the position closed
Bishop g7 I will retreat to h2 to be
ready to midnight h5 with g4 need to try
to prevent the c5 move I can even think
about getting the bishop on h2 and
playing after some preparation if
possible f4 2022 Clem Clem him down but
okay not not um something I really want
to play
so hot interesting I really don't think
that this is good night c 4 d 6 coming
here he can't play Knight to f6 but
Bishop b5 is good this looks tricky for
black my before porn is also week of
course but or can you play him he can
play five
but i'm a bit bit quick i am
threatening work t7 and because of this
liability this is somewhat shaky Bishop
he cannot defend rock d7 at the moment
moop the ADA can take and take you five
so you cannot oppose on the D file and
rope the seven is a threat here we go oh
can you why not really am yeah this is
good can just do that keep it simple
hmm
yeah 95 was what i was thinking about
maybe this one it's a little little
annoying move key 8 and in black king
aid hey Kimmy aid maybe I can answer
Knight b6 and Knight b6 yeah all i might
just just playing this like a complete
[ __ ] maybe
if i take f6 and tonight
hmm
analysis could actually have f6 now
hangs and then of course the rook hangs
he needs to move the rock now to be aid
and then I can take f 6 30 need to move
the rock now just this isn't this good
or wait wait wait yeah okay let's play
this I thought I thought this would be
would be excellent now because of 96
coming chef
so check assam isn't yo tech but i can
take here and still he can take before
unbelievable okay maybe this one it's a
good attacking f5 and ask him what what
what I playing next move I just intend
to take that's it's not so easy to make
a move even if he takes I will be able
to take you for ok grab don't know I can
just take this
kaftan should be winning at game rook h8
is a big threat and they're taking f5
think I'm winning the pants now
I can all give it but this is really
passive
just trying to push the pawn and now I
can take just want it done want it to
have root 2
ok this is this is the easiest trying to
get your form check
check
okay black yeah this was nice I really
liked it but I think he this naughty
formless was a really miss time move
here it must be about equal I don't
think that there is something for white
v I think it just needs to somehow
improve them the piece is a bit too to
get to get to play and get to play you
five then you should be ok but this is
this is really helping white much he has
a hard time not to play you five now
because I have those ideas like 96 95
attacking b7 you must do their problem
and this is just a very unlucky set up
when we cannot prevent this invasion
yeah I actually didn't see teeny ate at
first Knight b6 is good yeah and now 97
is even stronger okay no no no another
come comes with just talked to them yet
it looks it looks excellent now
switching from d6 and even g4s the comp
will see a good game obviously it seems
like up later played decent game iya ya
can can also take off my first it's not
much of a difference now here I can
actually just take I was some are still
thinking okay not really to please but
it's not doing much just taking a five
is simpler than pushing the edge poem
okay but it's just just to win in any
case yeah I think night before as an
instructive mistake here he also cannot
um which is important it was a bit too
much he cannot play this move because um
this would win the pawn I'll need to
have a big big big issues at least candy
can try that but it's just a bad
exchange of you or take here for example
this is this is a problem he cannot
avoid this f5 Nazi for business yeah
thanks for watching and two with acaba
if someone's maybe someone can write it
in the comments